Stanley spent most of
his career as the writer,
director,
editor and producer of marvel comics.
He created some of the world's most
popular comic book characters like
Spiderman,
iron man,
the hulk,
and the rest of the Avengers.
While started out as the creative ideas
of a teenage boy evolved into one of the
most profitable movie franchises
in all of history down biographics,
we're going to talk about
the legendary life of Stanley
[inaudible].
On December the 28th of 1922 Stanley
Martin Libor was born in New York City.
His parents,
Jack and Celia,
where Romanian Jewish immigrants who
left for a better life in the United
States.
His father was a tailor,
but he was laid off during
the Great Depression,
so they were constantly
struggling to make rent.
His parents could only afford
a one bedroom apartment
and they did their best to
provide for their son.
His mother and father slept on the couch
and allowed him to have a real bet.
Most of the memories Stanley had of his
father was seeing him sitting at the
kitchen table,
flipping through the want ads in the
newspaper trying to find a new job.
These were usually gigs
that never lasted very long.
Eventually his father would find steady
work and their lives would improve at
least a little.
When he was nine years old,
his mother gave birth
to his younger brother,
Larry,
I'm saying.
Yeah,
he got a bicycle for Christmas.
Stan took this opportunity to ride his
bike all over New York City and hardly
spent any time at home getting
to know his younger brother sins.
His parents were struggling
so much with money.
They encourage stand to get good grades
so that he would have a brighter future
than they did and they encouraged him
to find part time jobs as soon as he
could.
It took this very seriously and even
skipped a few grades so that he could
graduate from high school sooner.
He attended an all boys school and since
he was so much smaller and younger than
his cost made see
struggle to make friends.
It was often daydreaming
about his favorite movies
and often had his nose in a
book.
As soon as he was old enough to work,
he got his first job at a garment factory.
The year later he moved on to become
an usher at a movie theater called the
Rivoli.
He loved this job because he was allowed
to see as many movies as he wanted for
free.
It was also able to make
money doing something that
he enjoyed and it also helps
him to relieve as
parents financial stress.
He begins to pay for his own expenses so
that his parents could focus mostly on
his brother Larry,
even at a young age,
his parents and teachers could tell that
he would grow up to be someone special
at this stage in his life stat.
Imagine that he would be more involved
in the movie business is either an actor
or maybe a screen right at his favorite
movie growing up was the 1935 film
captain blood,
which was about swashbuckling
pirate adventures.
He loved the elaborate fight scenes and
would often imagine becoming the hero of
these films at 15 years old.
Stan ends at a writing contest
for the New York Herald Tribune.
He wasn't and the editor reached out to
him to say that he should pursue writing
as a full time career.
Seeing as he had high school early,
he was able to get a job writing
a bitters for a newspaper.
That's after a while he felt that this
was pretty boring and indeed quite
morbid,
so he tried to see what
other opportunities were out
there for young writers was
16 years olds.
He got a job at timely
comics assisting that artist,
Jack Kennedy ends the head writer,
an editor or Simon,
the overarching publishing
company actually made most
of their income from pulp
fiction and comics were more
of an afterthought for them.
In the beginning,
Stan was pretty much hod just to make
coffee and erase the pencil marks on Jack
Kirby's drawings as well as
do various other errands.
Hasn't gone was any $8 a week
and if we consider inflation,
that's about $141 today.
So back then timely comics followed the
trends of whatever was popular at the
time.
Now DC comics within main
competitor and they had superman,
so the characters they created,
we'll often they recycled
idea in one way or another.
At this point in time,
Jackie Kirby and Joe Simon has already
been inventing superheroes like the human
torch and Captain America.
Stan was eager to move on
from just making coffee,
so he pitched a story for a captain
America scripts off to the third issue was
published.
They liked his ideas and they agreed
to use it in the following issue.
This is when he decided that
his pen name would be Stan Lee,
which is just as first named Stanley's,
but at half.
He figured that someday he could move
on to become a novelist under his real
name standing the Martin Neba
when he was 18 years old,
Stanley,
you had been working at timely comics
for two years and he was assisting Jack
Kirby and Joe Simon with all the
various duties of that company.
Both Kirby Simon were having a financial
dispute with marvel comics as publisher
Martin Goodman,
and they decided to quit.
Stan was the only one
left and his lost Austin.
If he would be willing to step
into the role of head writer,
editor and Art Director.
This was meant to be a temporary fix.
Well,
Goodman searched for an
experienced replacements,
but it's stat and actually ended up
being great at doing all of these jobs at
once.
At the time,
he mainly focused on producing the
captain American comics because you know,
the 70 24 hours in a day and he
already had his work cut out for him.
At that time,
the comic book industry,
it was absolutely booming because people,
they wanted to escape the fears that
they had about the war by reading stories
of heroes both in the newspapers and
in fiction World War Two at this point,
it was absolutely raging.
Jack Kirby and Joe Simon.
They'd already established a theme of
Captain America coming face to face
without Offit and on
more than one occasion.
So Stanley carried on the legacy by acting
out his fantasies of being in combat
overseas,
Captain America comics and spired
Stanley to become a real hero himself.
He stays is I myself,
got so caught up in all of that.
Next thing I knew I had
enlisted in the army.
I fell it's all nation,
was really in danger and so I couldn't
live with myself if I were a civilian and
other people wherever that fighting.
However,
Stanley was not expected
to go overseas and fight.
The army recruiter looked over his resume
and gave him the job of playwright.
He was told to stay in the United States
and write scripts for training films
and public service announcements that
were shown to soldiers even if this was
not exactly the fight
that Stan was looking for.
This was actually a pretty big deal and
all of the army play went on to have
successful careers
including Theodore Geisel,
who is better known as Dr Seuss.
So when he was 23 years old,
Stanley was discharged from the army
and he moved back to New York City to
return to his job where the name had
been changed from timely comics to marvel
comics
when's only returned to New York City.
He began to go out on dates and
attend a lot of parties and do.
He was actually pretty embarrassed to
tell people that he worked for marvel.
A lot of women would actually just walk
away in mid conversation as soon as they
heard him say comic books.
Clearly these girls were not
the one for him all his life.
Stan would be doodling pictures of the
perfect girl that he always imagined that
he would find some day and it was like
you could see a vision of the future.
One night he showed up to a party when
a young woman named June Clayton on,
so the door stand was shocked because
this was the exact same girl he had been
dreaming about his entire life.
He blurted out,
hello,
I think I'm going to
fall in love with you.
Joan laughed and she thought this and the
fact that he wrote comics was actually
quite charming.
The only issue was that she
was married to someone else.
She was originally from England and she
had become a war bride and moved to the
United States with a new husband to
pursue a modeling and acting Korea.
She ended up fast husbands.
They were no longer happy
together and once she met Stan,
she knew that it was time to
make her divorce official.
When Stanley was 25 the do you got married
and instead of having a fancy wedding
or a honeymoon,
they use that money to move to long
island where they lived in a penthouse
apartment.
When Joan first got pregnant,
she painted that entire house pink
because she wanted a daughter so badly.
This early works and she gave birth to
a baby girl named June Juni out who they
nicknamed JC.
A couple of years later,
they had a second daughter named Jen.
Sadly,
Jen died after only being
alive for seven days.
This was such a traumatic experience
for Joan that she didn't want to have
children again.
They tried to a dark twist.
They run into a lot of issues.
Since Dan was Jewish and
Joan was episcopalian,
nearly every adoption agency rejected
them because of the differences in
religious beliefs.
While all of this was very tragic and
difficult for Stanley and his wife opened
up his eyes to so many issues in the
country that he had been unaware of until
this point.
Indeed,
it would become a catalyst for his
motivation to inspire other people
[inaudible]
as work.
Stanley was still incredibly dedicated
with his time at marvel comics.
They called their staff the
bullpen because they were
pumping out a one complete
comic every working day.
He made sure to give everyone on the team
credits with the names on the cover of
each comic book,
which was brand new for the time.
He also gave the group the nickname of
the Marion marvel and marching society
after he established more of a
leadership role in the company's down.
Eventually convinced artists Jack Kennedy
to returns a marvel comics since he
was one of the most talented
men in the business.
Cubbies.
Artwork brought Stanley's ideas to
life in a way that no one else could,
even though he was not an
accident in the traditional sense,
Stan was known for acting out the
roles of the characters when working as
Marvel's editor,
Erin's awesome director in order to
explain what he was looking for in the
storyline,
rather than giving an office stay
fully written script to follow,
Stanley would give them a general story,
nine of what was going to happen and
so he wanted everything to be overly
dramatic like people in a silent film.
Once the artwork was done,
Stan would go back and fill in the
bubbles with the appropriate dialogue.
This cut down on time.
Significant man.
It was cool.
The marvel method in the
1950s they psychologist named
Frederick what and claims
that comic books and television were
corrupting the youth in America.
In 1954 the Senate subcommittee on
juvenile delinquency announced the comic
books were actually dangerous.
They started the comics code authority,
which puts strict rules of
censorship on what types of contents,
where to be allowed to be
published in comic books.
Every new story line had to be approved
by the comics code or authority as the
cover of the book would have the seal
showing that it had been checked for any
indecent contents.
According to the rules,
the mention of any crime at all,
it was enough to have a comic
rejected this censorship.
It was a devastating blow to marvel who
made their bread and butter on superhero
stories about fighting crime.
Stanley had to lay off almost all of
the artists and they had to discontinue
many of that comics.
He was forced to write new stories that
were aimed at young children and they
were incredibly bland and boring
compared to writing about sue Harris.
Stanley trudged through this job for
over a decade after working in the Comic
Book Industry for 20 Years.
Stanley was having a
bit of a midlife crisis.
He had been writing these
Sydney children's from
experts so long that he really
wasn't sure he wanted to stay in the
industry and DDT was already writing
screenplays and newspaper articles on
the side and he was considering leaving
the comic book industry
in order to write a novel.
The only problem was that he still
had a wife and child to support and he
couldn't walk away from a paycheck.
He had a conversation with his wife,
Joan,
and she encouraged him to take a chance
and try to write a comic for adults.
Even if it went against
the censorship rules,
they decided that if it's published,
a hated it.
The worst thing that could happen
was that he would be fired,
but well,
he was ready to quit anyways,
so really have nothing left to lose.
This is when he decided to
create the fantastic four.
These characters,
they're multidimensional.
They didn't always enjoy
having their superpowers.
They don't with very real issues with
one another as well as they are in a
turmoil,
but that time superheros
from both companies,
they were really one dimensional
characters like captain
America or or Superman.
It turns out that the audience responded
really well to the fantastic four and
this ended up becoming
extremely successful.
Lovell's published a
couldn't deny the number,
so they continue to make more issues
despite the disapproval and lack of stamp
from the Comics Code Authority.
Once he was able to express his ideas
within the pages of marvel comics,
Stan Lee discovered a
new love of the industry.
He began to create more
characters like a man who he,
based on himself as a teenager,
each one of these characters was a
direct reaction to the world around them.
For example,
the hope was written during the Cold
War when people were afraid of nuclear
science.
Iron man was a response to the hates for
the military industrial complex and the
x men where a social
commentary on tolerance for
people who are different from
us.
In 1966 Stanley created black panther who
was the world's first black superhero.
He was revolutionizing to the industry
and just about every single way during an
interview,
Stanley said that the
1960s and seventies well,
some of the best years
of his entire career,
and again going on tours to
universities around the United States.
By this point,
the children who grew up in the 1950s
that we're told that comic books would
corrupt they're impressionable minds,
well embracing them once they reach
their teens and that 20s young people,
everyone looked up to Stanley.
He gave lectures on story writing.
In reality,
Stanley was gathering data around his
fans and his off to every Q and a session.
He was writing down notes about ways
that he could improve the marvel comic
storyline.
In the 1970s Stanley became
the head publisher of Marvel.
You decided to hand over the
responsibility of the scripts,
do other writers on the marvel team.
As he tried to take the superhero
characters to California,
he convinced the executives at marvel
comics to let him move his family out to
Los Angeles and they
opened up new offices,
gold marvel productions on the west coast.
It started the cartoon series of iron
man is one called spider man and his
amazing friends.
In 1988 he became the head of marvel
films and began to produce feature length
movies.
This ended up being a great
business move because Spiderman,
he soon became a household name.
Unfortunately not everything that
marvel studios produced was a success.
They tried to create a show
called the amazing Spiderman,
which add on cvs,
but Stanley,
he thought it was awful.
He scheduled a meeting with cvs and tried
to give some creative direction about
how to make the story better,
but they ignored his in Burton
carried on doing it their way.
They should have listened to his advice
because the show was canceled after just
four episodes.
Hollywood studios were having a hard
time seeing the potential of these comic
book stories and didn't know how they
put them on the big screen lease dated.
It's hard to explain the frustration.
We had these characters and we knew how
they should be portrayed and there were
people who wanted to do them,
but nothing really jelled.
In 1997 the popularity of
comic books drops dramatically.
Children were still watching the marvel
animated series like x men on Saturday
mornings,
but the profits of the
company went really downhill.
While it seems almost impossible
to imagine this today,
marvel comics actually had
to file for bankruptcy.
Thankfully,
even though the company was broke,
they still maintained the copyright
to all of their characters,
which was a gold mine.
During this time of uncertainty,
Stanley was approached by investors.
You suggested that he start a whole
new company called Stanley media,
which specialized in creating cartoons
and comics that were streamed on the
Internet.
They started in 1999 and the venture
became incredibly successful.
They were able to hire over 200
people to work on that stuff.
Unfortunately,
some of the executives were actually
arrested for securities fraud.
It turns out they had taken advantage
of Stanley's name and his reputation for
that own financial gain.
Stanley decided that the only way to
avoid the scandal was to start his own
company called POW entertainment.
One of his most popular characters was
stripped rela voiced by Pamela Anderson.
Eventually level was able to get back
on their feet and they had Stanley under
contract so that they could continue to
get as creative guidance to make sure
that the movies were done right.
After decades of dreaming
of being on the big screen,
Stanley was finally about to appear in
Hollywood blockbusters because he made
sure that his contract included cameo
roles in each new marvel movie that came
out for the rest of his life.
Reassignments was not
an option for Stanley.
He loved his job that much.
Stanley Martin Levy,
he passed away on November the 12th
2018 and it was 95 years olds and lives
every moment to the fullest with
a sense of joy and enthusiasm.
Even if the man is gone,
the legend of Stanley will live on forever
as being one of the most influential
people in comic book history.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
I've got brand new videos just
like this every day of the week,
but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now,
why not checking out some of the
videos I'm linking to on the screen?
And as always,
thank you for watching
eight.